good evening tonight a snapshot of the
political state of plain fact is the
first look at polling from 8 news now
emerson college and the hill we asked
about the november election the
president issues impacting nevada
politics now host john langler has the
results
it's been nearly a month since the
primary election the political playing
field is smaller but it's much more
competitive our polling shows major
races are tight but overall voters are
just unhappy inflation is high people
are worried about a recession because of
that it should come as no surprise 55
percent of nevadans we polled think the
nation's headed in the wrong direction
spencer kimball is with emerson college
which conducted the poll more concerning
for the president is on questions about
inflation and about gas about half of
the voters are blaming the president for
those higher prices president biden's
approval rating is around 33 percent
that's lower than the supreme court and
nearly eight points lower than governor
steve sisilak he has a nearly 40 percent
approval rating steve sibelius is
politics editor with the review journal
i was actually kind of surprised given
all the publicity and all the attacks
that he has endured
during some of these primary races that
that he is ahead as far as he is in his
re-election race against clark county
sheriff joe lombardo right now sisalak
leads in our poll 44 to 40 percent
nearly 9 want someone else and around 7
percent are undecided that's a trend
kimball noticed across all of his
polling the number of undecided voters
this far out from election tells us that
there's a lot of campaigning that's
happening in the state currently
tomorrow we'll take a look at the senate
and the congressional races we'll also
examine nationwide and statewide issues
we included in the poll john langley
live local now